[Music]
scary boy was it scary
it's very demoralizing and it makes me
feel helpless it's a chance for these
people who are long did none of my
life's that they now speaking to us
telling us is the story of the war
sometimes when people say what was the
worst day of it was fought for choice
rating it's one of the strongest storms
ever to hit the United States with
powerful winds torrential rain and a
storm surge higher than most houses
hurricane Michael came ashore with winds
of 155 miles an hour destroying
buildings and knocking out electricity
potentially for weeks tens of thousands
of people were warned to evacuate before
the storm arrived but many chose to stay
I spoke to them about why
the wind before the I came over the top
the wind was just incredible to see I
mean it was just absolutely incredible
because I could open my front door
because of the security bars and screen
and we could see out we watched a lot of
the trees fall it was honestly it was
beautiful it was absolutely beautiful
um scary boy was it scary what was it
like undescribable hail you couldn't see
you look out the windows and you got
people to pieces from people's houses
flying by you got trees flying by and I
like to say it was crazy as soon as
we've seen the roofs are tripping up
over there we ran to the bathroom and we
stayed in the shower and then once the
roof the roof ripped off it was pulling
us out of there and when the wind was
like pulling us out of that little room
I thought these walls would have went
next but they didn't thank God
the hallways were flooded the whole roof
is torn off and our room was next
actually for the roof to come off we
just stayed there and waited and just
you know have faith in the Lord I got a
million kids so if anything was to
happen it was them that I was thinking
about first think about for me it's
these guys so you know we we made it
kept a little look out the window there
was snapping trees like twigs but you
know I didn't let them look at none of
it I never had devastation like this but
I got my memories but it still hurts so
bad to see all their house I knew
everybody on this business block
everybody we're all like family we'd all
get together have cookouts and
everything I don't know what they're
gonna do
the family of a Durham University PhD
students who are appealing for his
release after it's been revealed he's
been held in solitary confinement in the
Gulf for five months
matthew hedges was arrested at dubai
airport as he tried to return home at
the end of a research trip it's thought
he's been accused of spying if he was a
spy he would be absolutely terrible
because he would be far too conspicuous
he was doing research and he was very
transparent about with what his research
was and he was very open about it these
months have been hell on earth to him as
they have to me because I haven't been
able to be there for him with his
depression and anxiety which he was due
to start treatment for non-medicated
treatment after coming back from this
trip he has struggled five months in
solitary confinement with no access to
any reading material any audio visuals
and very limited human contact it takes
a huge toll on anyone let alone someone
who has a depression issue it's
frustrating it's heartbreaking and for
me as his wife and it is confident and
as the person who is willing to give up
on anything for him it just
it's very demoralizing and it makes me
feel helpless and it makes me question
humanity how how insensitive and how
lacking of emotion can you be to deny an
innocent man the right treatment for for
their illness many of my concerns and
many of my my police have haven't have
been dismissed by the yo-yo authorities
that to me is the big slap on the face
not just to Matt and to his family but
to Britain a decade has passed since UK
banks received five hundred billion
pound bailout from the British taxpayer
amid a catastrophic financial crisis and
the age of austerity that has followed
has been long and painful Sky News
analysis shows that UK growth has
remained so sluggish in the years
following the crisis with the recovery
even worse than America's Great
Depression here we were with a banking
system on the edge well I remember that
the meetings of the IMF and the g20
meetings people were visibly scared
because they could see that the entire
system was in risk of at risk of simply
toppling over sometimes when people say
what was the worst day of it your
support for choice really I suppose the
most vivid memory is the morning of
faith October 10 years ago when I took a
call from the then chairman of RBS which
is in the biggest bank in the world and
by size it was about the same size as
the whole of the UK economy and in the
bank was hemorrhaging money is a
shares have been suspended in the stock
exchange and he said what are you going
to do about it
I'm that's a very odd question to ask me
but you know he knew I we had a plan and
I said how long can you last and was a
pause and he said we're gonna run out of
money and they afternoon now you think
about it it had run out of money the
cash machines that had gone off the
drawers that are closed importantly it
wouldn't just be the customers of RBS
and West the customers of every other
Bank in the UK and I suspect America and
Europe would have said look if it can go
down so McCann my bank and they would've
been panicked people couldn't have got
money for their families I couldn't have
got money for petrol for the car and so
on so it was one of these things you
plan for things like that happening you
imagine they might happen but you get
the call and it is happening and you've
got to decide in a split second really
what are you gonna do about it and we
decided that we would do everything that
was needed to stop it collapsing is just
as well we did yes you look and ask
yourself how on earth could this have
happened
how could be people appear to be so
complacent but if you know we look now
where we are ten years later it is the
economic and political consequences of
this that of course breaks it and all
that that's what worries me more think
about a banking crisis it's tough and
it's bad but you know how to sort it and
it's painful to sort it and difficult to
sort of it you can sort it whereas now
we're in something where if you ask me
how do you sort where we are just now I
find that much more difficult to fathom
three years since the murder of Josh
Hansen a particularly violent random and
unprovoked stabbing in North London and
this is the face of the man police want
to talk to the suspect Shane O'Brien he
has a particularly vivid tattoo on his
back
the victim Josh Hansen's mother Tracy
Hanson is making an extraordinary appeal
for help she wants information that will
lead to the arrest of the suspect Shane
O'Brien clearly our policies in this
country are not as liberal as I would
like and I just thought okay I've got to
do it myself so I'll be the walking the
walking boards if you like the walking
poster and it is demean you know the
last thing anyone would want to do
especially a mother who's grieving her
child is to walk around with a man the
police would like to speak to in
connection of his mother on her chest
it's very painful it's very
uncomfortable for me and to even look at
these prices and Hanuma it's very
uncomfortable but what drives on the
back may be an obvious question what's
driving you to do it justice course yeah
you know put an end to this part of the
journey in my life I'll never actually
have justice because I'll never have my
son back but you know we have laws in
place in this country for the very
reason that we don't want people to walk
around that carry out acts of violence
that end up in their death
the fatality and a person that please
like speech in connection with that
needs to be used to answer to those
questions somebody knows where he is
what would you say there's more than one
person knows where he is obviously he's
been helped you can't just leave the
country in a private jets and then you
know travel around extensively and what
sort of people are helping him I have no
idea I have no idea but clearly people
that he's close to and associates I
guess I don't know friends
and you would say to them what I say to
them step in my shoes leave my pain
every single day sit around the photos
and the memories that's all I have left
of Josh his clothes the life that he
once had try and just if you can just
try for a minute just to imagine it just
watch a film that's a sad story line and
just put yourself into that some frame
and just feel that pain that's my pain
24 hours today it's the Great War like
you've never seen it before
and now the conflict described as months
of boredom followed by moments of Terror
has been brought to life in a colorful
new feature-length documentary I spoke
to director Peter Jackson who's best
known for the Lord of the Rings films
about his passion for the human accounts
of a brutal war it's a chance for these
people who are long did their all did
every voice you hear as a person my life
so but they now speaking to us telling
us the story of the law so one thing the
restoration did is it just bought their
faces to life at the you know the faces
of these people suddenly you don't
really notice them when they're all spit
up suddenly they kind of just come into
a focus almost that and in that wonder
they're seeing their faces I just
thought well we can't have any sound
other than the voices of the guys that
were there is sort of the restoration
lead me to suddenly understand what this
film has to be and I just thought well
let's make it a let's make a movie with
the images you know who restored images
that is basically this live each one's
telling their own story let's not have
any historian so I mean there's lots of
documentaries where historians talk
about the First World War
you know experienced various people it's
just literally until their story so
they're so by that they're not telling a
story of the strength of the strategy
and tactics because as somebody said as
one of the guys said they didn't know
what was happening other than what was
actually in front of in front of their
eyes was all they knew because they
weren't told anything because of the
secrecy they wouldn't they didn't know
what the guys are marked a mile away
we're doing one mile really they only
knew what was in their media
desiring was the first world war was
this tiny little yeah you know tiny
little picture of what's happened to
them and it was their war personally it
was you know my grandfather was in the
First World War
so even though it's nothing to do you
know the film doesn't you know have him
in it and because he died in 1940 and
there's no pictures of him but you know
you know it was still the personal to me
because you know it's the film is about
the common experience of being an
infantry soldier on the Western Front so
you know when these guys talk about the
food they're reading back to the food
and food that I'm sure that that my
grandfather ate the same food you know
so I was certainly certainly really
understanding a lot about my
grandfather's life in those years you
know through the voices of the guys
telling us their story in the UK one in
seven women will be diagnosed with
breast cancer in their lifetime in
fighting the disease is a cause close to
the heart of actress Liz Hurley who lost
her grandmother to the illness breast
cancer awareness month she told us about
taking part in research exploring the
benefits of an active lifestyle to help
combat cancer know how we're always told
by doctors you know stress is a killer
you know relax everybody we're like yeah
well yeah great okay but what's really
fascinating about what Dame Leslie is
doing right now as they've um they've
been doing an experiment where they've
been seeing that um cortisol the stress
hormone in cells which they've been
looking at and they've been seeing when
they've been adding cortisol to a cell
which then also being treated by
chemotherapy that if the treatments much
less effective if this cortisol present
in the cell so they're now really
thinking that in fact stress not only is
it our killer just sort of as everybody
says it can actually affect possibly the
efficiency of your treatment so what are
the stress relieving tactics that can be
because obviously part being yourself
fit exercise that's the commonly known
to be a good stress reliever but if
you're in the middle of chemo doesn't
strike them that might not necessarily
be the best way for some of the ladies
we spoke to you they said that there's
some other complementary services that
are going alongside some of them in meet
havin reflexology during their
chemotherapy treatment but I thought
also what was interesting is that I
didn't actually know that exercise
relaxed you I thought that exercise
revved you up so I actually did this
court as
test and they took you know blood up -
not blood saliva at different times and
it might cause my puzzle levels were at
their lowest after going for a nice
brisk walk and I thought it would be
after lying on the sofa watching Netflix
I thought that would be actually when
you relax the most interestingly it
isn't it is moving around and so in fact
they said that even though sometimes
when you know you are at your tiredest
you want to just lie down you should
this week I sat down with the chef and
poverty campaigner Jack Monroe to talk
about the impact of austerity her
decision to publicly identify as
non-binary infamous spat with Katie
Hopkins that left the broadcaster
bankrupt and whether she has any
ambitions to stand as an MP some of the
best work and most important work that I
do is with food banks with the trust of
trusts Food Bank network with sort of
giving away books teaching people to
cook giving away recipes working with
them to develop recipes to teach people
to cook with basically food bank parcels
because poverty is a problem in our
country and food poverty is is a part of
that I just wonder what you make when
you hear the government saying we're
doing more to help hard-working families
we're doing more to help single mothers
single parents with their child care
you've lived that situation and you've
heard those words so I just wonder how
that makes you feel so I think on the
one hand there's a well-meaning segment
of government who think they're doing
like conservative Christianity going oh
well we're gonna we're going to help you
to help yourself
you don't get it they don't get it
because there's no one making those
decisions that understands what a couple
of weeks delays in benefits what the
impact of that is on somebody whose real
life you did get caught up with a very
now-famous its back with Katie Hopkins
on Twitter that ended up in a libel case
which she lost and and I'm just
wondering how you feel now because news
came out that she has gone bankrupt as a
result and as we talked about slipping
into debt
poverty I just wonder if you have
sympathy with her given that if she'd
have apologized you would have drawn a
line under it but now it's got to this
stage I don't think either of us
expected it to get to here when it's
when when it started to be honest I
thought that she would just apologize
because that's the simple and cheapest
thing to do is to just say sorry but she
didn't she was offered many many
opportunities to pull out of legal
proceedings like at one point I just
said I just want an apology no donation
no nothing just please just apologize in
a meaningful way because I've got so
much abuse a to this I just want you to
publicly stand down and and she didn't
do it and I think it's really sad where
it's ended up can you ever see your
sweet self switching from campaigner to
politics yes so I've always said when my
son is old enough that he can let
himself in through the back door and
cook himself a meal I'll consider it
and maybe that gives me a few years to
sort of work out where I'm politically
aligned there's a celebrity in politics
have long been entwined but in recent
times nor more so than with one couple
in May the US president welcomed Kim
kardashian-west to the Oval Office
following her campaign to free a woman
from a life sentence in jail and now
he's opening his doors to the social
media stars husband Kanye or yey as he's
now likes to be known it was something
about when I put this hat on and maybe
feel like Superman you may get a
Superman now that's my favorite
superhero
you don't look good we don't look good
Oh should politics and celebrity mix or
should they stick to their day job and
leave the law making to politicians I've
been catching up with labour councillor
and the drummer in blur say graduates so
why did you want to get involved in
politics I mean you say that it's
low-level port it's nevertheless his
politics you're a county councillor yep
well I'm a community activist so I knock
on doors trying to looking for problems
to solve and being account being account
so that was sort of a an extension of
that really meant I can actually walk
and roll and you know that lifestyle and
ice cream vans and being on stage and
all I didn't want to do it instead no no
I'm just greedy I guess no I was looking
for I when I was young I thought that if
only I could be a pop star you know this
void inside we will be filled and I
could finally be happy it came to her as
a big shock to me to find out when I was
a pop star that it didn't fill the void
at all and I was actually less happy
with them more happy it turned out what
filled the void was meeting up with
people one on one trying to solve
problems in their lives so I took on a
lot of different responsibilities in
association with that and that's
something you don't get as a musician
and something I think a lot of musicians
find their missing in their lives it's
an odd thing quite possibly and you've
seen it with I seen it with lots of
other musicians as well and I've had
that conversation with lots of other
musicians you know who are driven to do
it thinking oh if only I could be famous
then you know I could feel good about
myself and finding when they are famous
doesn't make any difference so yeah I
think a lot of people a lot of musicians
have a sort of midlife crisis as I did
and find themselves drawn towards you
know being a bit more helpful could you
know I was slightly rolling my eyes when
can us was saying it's not about me what
do you say to people when they say oh
you know you're just doing it to raise
your profile ahead of the next tour or
whatever well do we being a county
council city could profile right except
in university ward where my star rises
but no you know the politicians and and
artists of various guises have often
looked at each other because artists
have an awful lot of influence but they
have no power
whereas politicians have no influence at
all but have all the power
what's happening with blur well there
are no plans at the moment we all
finished the last banter touring and
record releasing saying we must do that
again that was fun so I guess at some
point it will probably happen but there
are no plans at the moment okay well
we're looking forward to it whenever it
might be come on and tell us as soon as
you've decided you'll be the first to
know okay
you
[Music]